how about Ryan from Costa Mesa you hear
he's a sitcom character the next-door
neighbor friend Ryan says he's here with
his beautiful fiancee Caroline sweet you
of buckers are good take you on the road
with us
I've just started listening to your
podcast religiously but I've blown
through all of them in the past six
months or so Jesus I find myself alone
occasionally in my room locked in my
room for hours listening to your show
like a fourteen-year-old boy that's just
discovered porn anyway I've been trying
to turn Caroline onto the show but I
can't fully sink the hook she giggles a
little when I play it in the car but I
don't think she's listening when I'm not
around or anything
she never biased tickets to the show
tonight because she knows I love you
guys and I thank her wholeheartedly for
that but I have a request do you think
the Germans could try to convince
Caroline that she needs more Babylon in
her life and while you're at it if
you're in a convincing spirit could you
let her know there'll be a good idea for
her to let me untie her balloon not this
evening yeah that's a certain [ __ ]
way to get there yeah ask us we're the
bridge I don't think you want untie the
balloon just falls out I think I think
the balloon night has to stay tight
anyway the Germans will do their best
anyway
[Music]
nine nine knots not Nazis at all if you
want ties the balloon Matt it goes no
that's if you keep it nice and tight if
your how do you get in if it's going
it's like fighting a hurricane to get
inside taking off and you're trying to
catch it
Caroline Caroline Ryan wants to hump
your dupa he does not want you to say
Carol nine if I'd you to say Carol yes
put it there all right that's why you
should listen to Babylon more often
because then you would know this was
coming
yeah you could have said nine I'm not
going to see that sure meet you at the
Braille improv and this is gonna come a
lot smoother and easier than Ryan's [ __ ]
I'll show you yeah
he's got one of those dicks that's thin
at the top and fat at the base how do
you know this I know these things
curious how you came by this information
the arrays are making you talk I am
German he knows things in any event
welcome to the show we'll come in we're
comin comin give me Wilkinson I be the
same Caroline my Liebchen
[Applause]
[Music]
you